hello everyone welcome to today's live
webcast titled challengers in theory
management and vanilla Lucic of a bit
molecular and I will be a moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you to this educational webinar
presented by lab routes and sponsored by
avid molecular where a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on support button at the top right of
your presentation window or submit your
problems through the Q&A button lower
left-hand corner this is an educational
webinar and that's offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credits I
would like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. David Hilliard is a
professor of pathology at the University
of Utah School of Medicine and medical
director of molecular infectious
diseases in area P laboratories dr.
Hilyard received his medical degree from
Columbia University his training was in
anatomic and clinical pathology with
fellowship in Medical Microbiology
microbial genetics dr. Hilyard is won't
renown care well with over 80
peer-reviewed publications and numerous
chapters and review articles I will now
turn it over stop the hillier for his
presentation welcome to today's
teleconference today we'll be discussing
the important role in challenges for
molecular testing and the man
mnDOT's CMV infection our learning
objectives are to take an overview of
the role of nat testing in the
management of CMV to consider the value
of CMV test standardization and look at
recent insights into the challenge of
CMV standardization and implications for
other viral load tests I must say I was
tempted to add another learning
objective and that would be to
appreciate a fascinating unfolding
scientific mystery that impacts one of
the most important areas of molecular ID
testing indeed that's the story I'll be
reviewing with you today I have two
disclosures to give consultation to
Abbott Diagnostics and rush Diagnostics
shown on this slide the content of this
presentation is consistent with all
applicable FDA requirements for approved
assays it has long been appreciated that
immune suppression whatever its root
causes places individuals at risk for
serious pathogen infection we now know
about many primary genetic defects
causing immune suppression we've known
for some time about the vulnerability of
nyan aids in the premature infants for
immune suppression and therefore
pathogen infection HIV patient immune
suppression is another famous story as
well as that of cancer patients or put
on a variety of immune suppressive
regiments and probably the one that is
most relevant to this presentation is
that of the situation for transplant
patients one of the most significant
developments in laboratory medicine in
the last 10 to 15 years has been the use
of various molecular technologies to
guide the management of care for immune
compromised individuals a common theme
is that pathogens which often pose
extreme risk to immune suppressed
individuals can be detected and
quantified at early stages of disease
and followed quantitatively in order to
assess response to therapy
this approach leads to a much more
refined and effective personalized level
of care it should be recognized that
immune suppression actually appears in
several different settings this
presentation will focus on the use of
molecular technology for management of
transplant patients and the development
of molecular test methods and algorithms
for their care molecular and of course
traditional tasks fit into a very
complex landscape of testing I like this
slide by Fishman which illustrates a
rough sequence of events in transplant
patient care highlighting stages of care
and windows of risk clearly CMV is not
the only pathogen that transplant
patients are at risk for however it's a
very important one and its study has
contributed enormous lis to the
management of other types of infection a
key concept is that the period of most
intense immune suppression is the stage
in which patients are at greatest risk
for any of these pathogens just as
institutions usefully rely on different
immunotherapy protocols they also
benefit from shared experience in
detection and quantification of these
organisms and tests standardization or
non standardization has become a major
issue it's worth remembering something
about CMV epidemiology and that it is a
ubiquitous infection humans are the only
reservoir and about 60 to 80 percent of
adults become seropositive not only in
this country but worldwide an immune
suppressed patient CMV is capable of
causing serious infection in many
different organs i well remember as a
young pathologist in training performing
a post-mortem on an individual who had
presented with CNS symptoms with
Toxoplasma infection diagnosed on a
frozen section biopsy this was shortly
before HIV
identified and mysterious cases
appearing in New York City samples were
taken for this post-mortem from
virtually every body compartment
remarkably CMV was identified in the
form of nuclear inclusions in almost
every tissue indeed full-blown CMV has
many presentations in severely
immunocompromised individuals causing a
variety of direct presentations there
are also many direct effects as
illustrated on the right side of this
slide these include a general change in
immune modulation the immune suppressed
state there is also an involvement in
acute and chronic rejection and
importantly it has been well documented
that their interactions with other
viruses including an acceleration of
hepatitis C virus pathogenesis and
evolution in post transplantation
lymphoproliferative disease driven by
epstein-barr virus so CMB an
immunocompromised hosts can be
summarized by some of these general
bullet points first the general features
which are nonspecific in the patient's
presentation spiking fevers myalgia
arthralgia the Ebola point that disease
presents at this stage of greatest
immune compromised that patients most at
risk are those who are naive
immunologically to CMV in the past that
is receiving a transplant from a CMV
positive donor into a negative recipient
and then the very important concept that
a large fraction of relevant disease
happens due to secondary infection due
to reactivation of latent virus in this
setting and both in the context of
hematopoietic stem cell transplantation
h SCT and in solid organ allografts one
of the most important and
life-threatening of the presentations is
pneumonitis and obliterated
bronchiolitis also in the case of solid
organelle
holographs it should remember that there
is a large role in renal rejection as
well so the gravity of pan lobular
pneumonia or a bluebird of bronchiolitis
driven by c and b is shown in this slide
you can see at the top the C and B
inclusions that would have been seen in
that autopsy in the HIV patient 30 years
ago and are routinely seen by surgical
pathologists in samples from the lung or
from other body sites for a first
indication that CMB is involved
now what about laboratory tools for CMV
diagnosis and patient monitoring clearly
we have had a timeline and a maturation
of capabilities for years we used
culture looking either of white blood
cells especially buffy coats we would
look by culture or in combination with
psychology and to bronchoalveolar lavage
and other sample types a intermediate
before molecular testing was the
development of the technology for
antigen emia in which case white cells
were purified and then were exposed to
monoclonal antibodies that would stain
the white cells if they were infected
with CMV at this point in time and
really for several years most diagnostic
testing has been driven by nucleic acid
amplification and quantitative analysis
out of very various sample types this is
now the gold standard and the important
bullet point is that in order to make
tests comparable one to another we have
been using an international standard
which was released in October of 2010
so in the case of CMB disease in the
transplant patient there are a couple of
general approaches the first is
antiviral prophylaxis that is we take a
patient on a transplant you need a unit
and put them on antivirals from the
get-go the drug therapies would
typically include balgan cycler there
beginning and engraftment for divine
periods of time up to a hundred days and
one of the downsides of this is that
putting all patients on this given a
risk of complications from bone marrow
suppression means that that entire
population of patients would then have
this risk in addition there may be
consequences and implications for the
evolution of resistance to CMV the other
approach is called pre-emptive therapy
in this case in the setting of a
symptomatic infection defined levels of
viremia detected by nucleic acid testing
are determined surveillance testing is
done typically once a week and for
periods up for three months although in
patients for instance graft-versus-host
disease settings and t cell deficiency
settings this surveillance testing can
go on for long periods of time up to a
year when viral loads for CMV have
reached the a defined threshold then
these patients are started on therapy
I've began cyclope oral bal gancyclovir
and we've just i've highlighted at the
bottom of this slide that it is so key
that these be validated through research
studies to have drug therapy starting at
predetermined viral load levels now in
this slide we have a very old study that
has been much cited that i think gives
us great insight to how testing is done
and also what some of the issues are on
the left side of the slide we see
from this patient cohort study average
viral loads for patients that either
have CMV disease on the far left or are
asymptomatic and you can see that for
CMV disease patients the average copy
per mil for hepatitis C is about 55,000
whereas asymptomatic patients may still
be positive but have lower levels of
cytomegalovirus 1,800 in this case
turning to the right panel the analysis
of sensitivity specificity and positive
predictive value is shown and let's hone
in on the positive and negative
predictive value for patients for which
therapy initiated at different viral
load levels were taken so at the bottom
of the slide for a cut-off of 20,000
copies per mil the positive predictive
value would be very high hundred percent
in this study at five thousand copies
per mil PPV at 64 percent and closer to
the cutoff levels that are routinely
used now the cutoff of two thousand
copies the positive predictive value is
50% the negative predictive value 99%
so to summarize pre-emptive therapy has
been the dominant therapy for more than
20 years it is the preferred strategy in
most institution and in this review
article by Solano and others that
appeared very very recently a lot of
data has shown that it's at least as
effective as prophylaxis in preventing
early CMV and organ disease there's
really wide agreement for this that's
summarized in this article now I've
highlighted two other bullet points from
this paper and that is that the issue of
the cutoff low CMV by ramya which can
often be cleared by the host with no
effects on patient survival there is
wide agreement for this notion that is a
patient
who might have 200 copies or 300 copies
or 800 copies there's wide agreement for
this but at least there is far less data
and so in this I think important new
article there is a highlighting of a new
study to support withholding treatment
until cnv reaches about 1500
internationally units per mil which is
also about 1,500 copies per mil and data
to show that this really has no
detrimental effect on patient survival
we need to have accurate and comparable
data for a number of reasons in order to
assess patients clinical course the
application of shared knowledge from
primary research and its translation
into the clinical setting is another
reason very important reason why tests
should be standardized and finally for
guidelines to be created that can apply
to a variety of institutions we need to
be care comparing apples to apples when
we look at CMV viral loads compared to
other CMV viral loads so are we there
were we ever there are we there now that
raises a definition which is at the
heart of comparable viral load testing
and that is the commute ability of
assays so if you look in the definition
literature of the clsi documentation
commute ability is defined as the
equivalence of the mathematical
relationships among the results of
different measurement procedures for a
reference material and for
representative samples of the type
intended to be measured Wow
that's really a mouthful I think that
language as complex as it is can really
be boiled down to the central question
can results from one test be applied to
those from another test so how do we
calibrate a test to begin with shown at
the top of
slide is a simple crossing threshold
plot in a real-time PCR assay and you
can see from the Green Line that as PCR
proceeds there's eventually signal above
noise a crossing threshold is determined
for that sample on the left bottom panel
we can see that these crossing
thresholds can in a dilution series in
this case be translated into a straight
line if the results are log transformed
because PCR is intrinsically logarithmic
and it's amplification cycles and then
in the bottom right panel we see that
these dilution series generated crossing
thresholds with the dilution series line
straight line plotted in blue can then
be compared to ace the crossing
threshold from a sample of a known
concentration shown in the green bars so
in this case we have a sample that is
known to have about 10,000 copies per
mil and if we intersect on the line and
go over to the left we find that this
corresponds to a crossing threshold of
25 and for those of you who aren't
familiar with this this is how all of
our viral load tests are essentially
calibrated so for this we need a
calibration material and indeed for the
reasons I've listed we need a commutable
erect or a comparable calibration
material one that everybody can share
and go through some form of this
calibration process so that we report
the same results the results must be
accurate and the calibration material
that is sent out month after month year
after year must have the same definable
concentrations that people can rely on
so where have we been in the past and I
think the simple conclusion is best
shown in this very well-known slide from
paying at all published in
transplantation in 2009 where samples
were sent out to 33 different
laboratories the samples consisted of
serial dilutions so one could look at
high medium and low viral loads it was
the material with spiked nucleo capsid
purified material spiked into plasma and
what is really shocking about this is
shown numerically in the second bullet
point but you can see it best just
looking visually here we have this
material that should result in about a
log three or 10,000 copies per mil but
in fact there are interrogations where
nothing is detected or just barely
detected and when we look around 3,000
copies per mil we can see that there's
just this tremendous spread thinking
back to the cut-offs in the humar paper
if we were to try to apply one set of
rules and had testing done in various
laboratories in example we would draw
very very different conclusions taking
that information just from this middle
range of values from the paying 2009
study and transposing enough onto that
ROC curve you can see just how
incredibly broad this spectrum is it
should also be pointed out that this
just isn't a problem for very low
samples although things probably get
more difficult for all PCR reactions at
the low end but also at the high end
tests for some reason can't seem to get
the same result among different
laboratories so one of the solutions for
this was to assume that the problem lay
in the fact that people were using
different calibrators of course if you
use a different material for that
calibration you would get different
results just like the ones that were
shown in the last slide so the released
international standard in 2010 came from
the National Institute of biological
standards and controls double it's
called the WHL international standard
and it is quote assigned a concentration
of IU units based on testing and a
number of laboratories so what happens
is these
samples for all of the viral load assays
get sent out and are testing a try
different technologies and then an
average of copies per mil is then taken
generally as the international standard
expressed in our units are you units so
based on this worldwide collaboration
material is created and then a next
important point is that the w-h-o has
really done a great job in having this
material be very robust both in shipment
and also over time so it's life alized
and as soon as you go into a quality of
life Allah zation environment take the
water away then the stability of all
kinds of samples including these viral
samples becomes tremendous we have just
life alized vials of this as an aside
from the w-h-o in other areas of testing
that we've had for over 10 years and we
essentially get the same results as we
come back and them apply them to
real-time PCR testing now a final
important point is shown at the bottom
of the slide is then that this bill that
the WHI does that people can start
calibrating to is not going to serve all
of the clinical testing community's
needs people are going to be
recalibrating their laboratory
development tests is this going to
happen for IVD assays as well so we
really need to have a much greater
supply of secondary standards and these
secondary standards need to very closely
match the primary standard so that
fortunately at this point in time it
wasn't always the case there are a lot
of available standards and you can see
this top bowl of some of the existing
standards that are there and I won't
comment on any of them I think these are
all terrific companies that are doing a
great job with secondary standards for
CMV more recently there's been a
application of technology beyond
quantitative PCR for matching the
very standard to the secondary standard
and that has been digital PCR digital
PCR as many of you know has a greater
capacity to for accuracy than qpcr and
in addition represents a direct counting
of molecules and obviates the needs for
generation of a standard curve when you
compare one sample to another so here
are two examples of digital PCR for
those of you not familiar with it the
top one is the type of PCR done in an
emulsion setting but the point is that a
dilution series is done into an array
format either in liquid or on a solid
surface as is illustrated in the bottom
panel and at a certain dilution and at a
certain density of the array you will be
able to count individual wells and
what's going on in those individual
wells is that let's take CMV as an
example there are PCR primers that can
amplify any single molecule that is
occupying that well and after a certain
number of amplification cycles we'll see
that it's positive so literally at the
end of the day individual molecules are
diluted they fall into a Wells they're
amplified and detected and it's like
counting jellybeans in a jellybean
bottle the attributes of this testing
compared to PCR certainly are that the
precision of testing is improved the
measuring range however which
illustrated in the top right slide is
very very broad 4q PCR is array
dependent the larger the array the
greater the measuring range but in
general certainly limited than qPCR the
important third point is the lack of
need for an external calibrator we are
just directly counting molecules and so
one of the things going forward to think
about is will we eventually get to the
point where we're not talking about
samples
send out to different laboratories
measured by qPCR but in fact just
directly counting control material by
digital PCR and having that count equal
our international unit so with the
advent of WHL standards did we fix the
problem and there's lots of literature
on this but I think a useful way is to
take the very very broad surveys that
almost all of us subscribe to from the
College of American Pathologists ask
what happens when you take proficiency
samples and send them around to a
variety of laboratories they're using a
variety of technologies so shown in the
green line is a set of assays and
without naming them I'll say these are
assays that are very well characterized
and in this green line set are
reiterations of testing with in fact
exactly the same masse in many cases and
if we look at the low value the high
value and the median value the numbers
are very tight and in fact they get
fairly close to what PCR is capable of
if however we look in the orange box
which includes all methods we can see
that in 2015 there are great differences
between the low values and the high
values and a drift in the median value
even a little bit finally for this slide
the left blue box shows that as of 2015
we had reporting in international units
but also reporting in copies and I can
tell you that has a strong incentive for
laboratories to be reporting in
international units only directing their
attention to the importance of
calibrating to this material recently
the reporting and copies has not been
called for so as a summary in 2017
here are some bullet points there's been
a widespread adoption of the w-h-o
standard there's been significant
improvement in CMV tests including both
ldt and fda-approved assays there has
been improvement in concordance of CMV
results for tests calibrated to the WHL
standard however significant
reproducibility differences among
different assays still remains so the
conclusion is that in 2017 despite all
of these great efforts we are still not
there yet so what went wrong what have
we been missing well first this is a
complicated process it's not like
digital PCR where you count wells on an
amplification microarray and calculate
the result for PCR you must calibrate to
a well-characterized standard material
so for both Ltd's and IV d's even with
experienced developers calibration might
not be done in in exactly the same way
secondly there could be variation in
secondary standards and indeed examples
of this have come to light and finally
let's remember that variation in test
chemistry's including extraction
selection of probes and primers and the
test instrumentation itself could
contribute to variation so very quickly
the status of secondary standards and
I'll just cite this excellent article
that appeared in 2014 using digital PCR
the boxes in the ride show a NIST top
right product which is actually raw
naked DNA that has been incredibly well
calibrated and quantified as well as can
really be done with with large sites
cytomegalovirus nucleic acid and then an
in-house assay and the WHL standard and
you can see that all of three of those
fall pretty much on top of each other
you can see that one of the standards at
the time and
I believe this is no longer the case but
at least one of the standards at this
time had a significant difference from
the concordance scene than the other
three panels at the bottom of the slide
I've just thrown in data from this paper
to show that digital PCR until it gets
down to very very low concentrations
really is capable of much lower CVS and
very very impressing reproducibility of
testing a second example to cite is
actually looking at FDA approved house
so we have two tests that are calibrated
to each other shown in the bottom left
panel and then you can see that in that
initial validation first test out and
then the second test gets calibrated to
it there is very very good concordance
but then when different materials are
used to test in again a cap survey you
can see that there are differences in
these two tests in the mean viral load
for the challenge samples so this hints
that something else is going on and
without going into the resolution of
this particular problem let's just
consider a similar observation to seen
when we compare these two FDA assays
overall they had good correlation but
their patient bias range from 0.4 to
greater than one log and their average
bias was 0.76 log there are other things
that could be going on and in this case
there really are important hints as a
couple of really nice review papers have
pointed out so scientists stand on each
other's shoulders an earlier work
sometimes isn't resurrected and its
importance considered but that really
has happened in the case of the CMV
story so one of the pieces of
information
we're thinking about is that when we
take the plasma sample it really is not
the infectious sample that's been known
for a long time in the setting of
transfusion and and other biological
settings so CMB replicates in leukocytes
and so if we want to find intact viruses
we know for sure they're in leukocytes
it's another question whether they're
actually present in this sample type we
call plasma secondly all the way back in
2002 in this paper by boomin colleagues
there was documentation that CMV DNA in
the plasma actually has as its major
form fragmented DNA so there's C CMB DNA
not only is it fragmented but by using
two different PCR amplify and asking
what percentage of signal came up in
these different amplicons it was
estimated that a large fraction of this
was quite small less than 2,000 base
pairs of course it's very challenging to
very finely fraction ate that but this
study was done all the way back in 2002
so it really challenges this widespread
assumption that we've had in our minds
doing viral or testing for a long time
that we take a plasmid sample inside it
as in the plasmid as an intact virus we
need to extract in order to break that
virus open that what pops out is large
genomic DNA we do PCR ona
we amplify and detect and get expect to
get the same results from lab to lab if
we've standardized well to a
communicable standard so the other
hypothesis that these early hints really
strongly suggested were that the size
fragmented material shown in the right
hand side is three different general
sized fragments if presented to a PCR
test
shown at the bottom could actually not
be amplified the same way a large
genomic piece of DNA would the upstream
and downstream primers shown in
lime-green here will amplify a large
fragment PCR tests in the past have
sometimes been 200 nucleotides
separating upstream and downstream
primers these days the primers tend to
be a little closer to each other but
still you can imagine that depending on
how small the average-sized fragment is
in plasma a significant amount of
nucleic acid in the plasma sample would
not be amplifying and then the most
important point is that if we have
different laboratories using different
PCR tests with different separations of
upstream and downstream primers then we
would automatically and strongly predict
that we would have non comparable
results and so there are a set of
studies that have come out just in the
last couple of years that have addressed
this question of for CMV straight-on so
this paper came out in the fall of last
year in which very focused experiment
was done taking ten PCR tests comparing
them directly to the w-h-o international
standard panel which is a dilution
series of samples shown on the left and
if you look at the observed versus
expected for the ten different samples
the slide male it'll be a little bit
difficult to see all of the details
there but you can see for sure that
there's separation of the different
assays and then plotted on the right in
order of the size of the amplicons going
from small on the left to larger on the
right are the results and the separation
of values compared among these different
assays so not only is there a separation
but in some cases there are even
dropouts
I really recommend this paper for those
of you are interested in this topic it
includes not only this very very
important and really definitive
information about what's going wrong
with our PCR standardization for CMV but
there's a tremendous discussion that
looks back on the background and really
puts it in its proper clinical setting
in terms of the reportable tasks here's
just a third panel from the same paper
showing that results that would be
reported out from a test really would
vary from test to test so let's begin to
wind down a little bit and just think
about as you're listening to this
webinar what would be your next
experiment so and I've just thrown up a
couple of possibilities here I mentioned
that in 2002 there was an initial
rudimentary characterization of the
circular DNA we learn from that study
that nucleic acid was fragmented it
tended to be small the problem with
looking at the nucleic acid and having
your experiment be to go look and see
exactly what the size fragments are
remember these are present in such small
concentrations you need things like PCR
to even know that they are there so you
need either some kind of hybridization
to do your experiment or some sort of a
new technology but you need a way to
actually look at those fragments to
clearly define the size distribution so
looking at the distribution is a tough
experiment and so beyond looking at size
distribution the experiment that is much
more straightforward to do and was just
published this last summer was to go in
and do the very simple experiment of
asking if it's extra viral then we ought
to be able
to make it go away by nucleating that
farther so that no PCR reaction can pick
it up
and so that's illustrated here back to
our size distribution in this experiment
samples were extracted and then they
were treated by a powerful DNA's
treatment and then this was plugged into
various PCR assays and this paper that
just came out in the Journal of
infectious disease with Tong and
colleagues took primers that would
create amplicons of different size
eighty-one base pairs 138 base pairs 578
base pairs for two different targets
with even two more primer sets and then
asked what was the amplify ability and
the results were really really dramatic
I'm just showing one of the result
slides from this paper which I also
recommend highly that you look at and
that is that a very very large number of
samples by far the the greatest number
of samples here after nuclease treatment
had no amplify Abul nucleic acid at all
so this just definitively shows that in
a typical see in the plasmid sample in
fact most of the nucleic acid is this
very very small freely circulating
nucleic acid so the major conclusions
then are that that most Israeli more
than 99% the distribution is quite small
and a proportion of it in fact is very
small less than 138 base pairs an
additional experiment that was done was
to knowing that it's free nucleic acid
to look at pre analytic conditions again
they've been looked at over the years of
course but their assessment in this
paper was that the free DNA is stable up
to 48 hours pre separation from white
cells finally and I recommend this paper
to you as well that was one that was in
initiated by Randy Hayden and others who
have I can't name all the names of
people who have been instrumental in
doing this work angie Caliendo and the
other authors that i've shown today but
looking back at cap samples not just for
CMV but also looking for epstein-barr
virus and other viruses looking at the
reported values and documenting the fact
that this is really a generalized
problem for other areas of testing as
well
so to summarize most plasmid C of the
CMB DNA is naked it's extra viral it's
substantially processed it's vulnerable
then to the vagaries of different
targeted PCR designs different assays
give different results depending on
their outlook on size and this applies
to all pathogens likely detected in the
plasma so what do we do in the absence
of a fix for this well you know I think
maintaining and there I certainly would
recommend I think most people would
recommend maintaining standardization to
whu-oh but recognize the fact that
different assays will have this problem
of non commute ability for the reasons
that we've outlined today so monitoring
the patient's clinical course using the
same assay is one way to assure that at
least we have comparative values for the
same patient during the same Treece
treatment scenario which has really been
a recommendation in general for quite a
period of time so what about digital PCR
going forward well I think an important
thing to remember is that even digital
PCR is capable of direct counting if we
have fragmented nucleic acid that is too
small for the amplicons of that digital
PCR test they will not be detected so we
cannot just commute ibly go from digital
PCR tests to digital PCR test perhaps
digital PCR assays that have very very
small apple con sizes or if they were
standardized in some way and did direct
measurements in fact would be a powerful
powerful form of testing going forward
digital PCR also has some through
petitions but this could be something
that's very important going forward we
can imagine missing nucleic acid
technologies in addition to digital PCR
of small amplicons what about wholly new
technologies I mean after all we have
technologies like next gen sequencing
where nucleic acids go through an ANA
pore and not only the detection of that
nucleic acid fragment even if it's very
small but a sequence for it is rendered
in the detection and we have other
assays where we increasingly reduce the
noise problem we're able to sensitively
hybridize with single probes a very very
small size perhaps technologies like
this will really be our final solution
down the road
certainly clinical testing going forward
will be tremendously impacted by these
studies that I've described to you today
with the knowledge of the non commute
ability of samples what will we do will
we have different assays with different
specific cutoff levels will they be
population specific as well as we
continue to do more and more studies
will tests eventually converge on the
same targets in the same amplicon sizes
or will we have these new breakthrough
technologies certainly what everybody
will agree with now and going forward is
that new clinical studies with full
appreciation of the need for a well
standardized PCR testing will need to be
done and so with that I'd like to thank
the sponsors of this tella conference
Abbott Laboratories and thank you all
for your attendance today
thank you dr. Celia for this very
informative presentation before we get
started on the Q&A I just want to remind
everybody that you can submit your
questions by clicking on the Q&A button
on the left-hand screen of your window
of your presentation window okay here we
go with the first question during your
presentation you discussed that given
with the w-h-o standardization we still
don't have full harmonization of the app
phase in your opinion what would it take
for that to occur well no matter what
technology you're talking about we
really have a tough challenge here and I
think that the solutions that come to
mind by authors of this paper have
brainstormed this and we talked about it
as we teach our residents here at the
University of Utah you know one solution
would be to have some sort of a
correction factor among assays I think
that's not very attractive the data that
we see so far suggests that amplicons of
about the same size will be pretty
commutable but there's many many targets
for all of our viral assays CMV is a
large virus and tests have already been
rolled out and validated so having
everyone use exactly the same amplicon
could be a solution but that's also not
a very attractive one
well this ad also that we don't know a
lot about different patients and to what
extent they're nucleic acid is
fragmented could it be at different
stages of disease in fact we see a
different size distribution of fragments
so frankly it's really a tough nut and I
don't have a great solution the points
that have been made about following the
patient with the same assay you know
generally stand standardizing to
secondary standards of the important
ones that come to mind for me for the
time being hey thank you
second question as you mentioned the
digital PCR may be a suitable herpes
symbol for connotation of herpes virus
can you elaborate imposing cons between
digital pieces pcl versus real-time
currently used
I mean FDA approved a thing yeah so
let's assume that we had community
bility and digital had been appreciated
for some of its good ability to be very
very reproducible there's still problems
with this platform it's it's used for
many many different applications in
these research studies it's been
absolutely tea but it's in its current
format it just doesn't have the
convenience and the long track history
that qPCR has QT CR of course were we
have such a command of that if you look
at cap studies for tests with the same
assay and look at the CVS for that it's
really a tremendous technology going
forward so we'll wait and see technology
and technology companies surprised us
but right now we just don't have sort of
the same cost-effectiveness the same
throughput in the same confidence that
we're not going to have problems as we
do with qpcr the next question is
current sensitivity of commercially
available seeing the assays in the low
arms of the dynamic range how does that
sensitivity impact patient management
and does it well the three fda-approved
tests go down pretty low and I hope I
made the point well that although we
don't have an absolute cutoff as a
trigger point for initiating therapy the
ballpark for most initiations of therapy
tends to be a thousand fifteen hundred
two thousand and so that's a big
separation between the sensitivity of
these tests also you read the literature
for the laboratory-developed tests
they're also very very low so in terms
of sensitivity the way algorithms are
used right now none of the PC
our tests have a sensitivity problem if
their significant demand for primary
sequencing to detect variance or perhaps
and drug resistant markers in the case
of CMV that's a very very important
issue and the number of targets and the
expanding number of drugs makes this a
dynamic process as one takes a patient
who's on therapy and current practice
and sees that on therapy akin to what we
see on a patient on HIV therapy and
there's a rebound to a higher viral load
then the standard of care is to do
resistance testing right now it's done
mostly by Sanger sequencing although a
number of laboratories are very working
very very hard to develop next-gen
sequencing assays I'll just throw in
another challenge there same as we've
seen for HIV is that having a curated
well curated set of mutations so that we
know what the correlation and the
outcomes are is a significant issue and
labs fortunately are working with each
other to make this kind of information
accessible to the whole community of
testers is there clinical value in
understanding potential difference
between violence-free DNA plasmid versus
intact violence and could this
potentially be you know an impact or
cause effect between somebody being on
therapy versus somebody not being on
therapy I think it's just so too early
to tell we we just as I mentioned don't
know what the size distribution is I
think that the good assumption is that
cells are infected with viruses and it's
not just CMV we need to start asking
what's going on in EBV other herpes
viruses and just infections in general
where we do quantity quantitation but as
soon as and maybe even before nucleic
acid is released from selves
the integrity of the virus is vulnerable
and we've seen over the years as we try
to take plasma fractions and to culture
with them
that culture is really difficult that's
another early hint that we had that what
we're seeing in our PCR assays is not
really the presence of intact virus so I
think with this information though
there'll be initiation of sort of next
generations of looking at pathogenesis
of viruses and and what is the integrity
of the virus in different body
compartments you know you you can't ask
those questions until you have the tools
to do them we're beginning to at least
have some experience with some of the
first generation tools for detecting
free nucleic acid but it's in its
infancy
thank you dr. Hilyard we're coming on
top of the hour so I want to be mindful
of that if there are no more questions I
would like to once again thank dr. Yulia
for his presentation and thank you all
for your attendance today as a reminder
today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through six for six
months from live dates you will receive
an email from loudly alerting you when
the webcast will be available for replay
thank you all for their attendance today
and goodbye